[Music]
[Applause]
our good buddy Robert Ory Lakers
Spectrum Sports commentator seven time
NBA champ he's known as Big Shot Bob and
he joins us courtesy of bet online you
can check out bet online for updated NBA
title Conference Division and awards Etc
updated win totals and player stats
Robert good to talk to you again when's
the last time you shot a jumper um
yesterday how's it looking it's still
looking good don't ask me to go up and
down the court though shooting standing
still is it's simple but going up and
down the court is a different thing all
right if I said Steph Curry greatest
shooter of all time the second greatest
shooter of all time is probably
clay I think clay yes I think Clay is
you know Steph might be 100 and Clay is
like 99.9 I don't think people realize
how great of shooter Klay Thompson is
okay I didn't know they were that close
though one is you know catch and shoot
where Steph Steph can create his shot
yeah you know for me is just being a p
shooter we not talking about you know
going off the dribble I'm just start
like just standing there and shooting I
think CLA is one of the best shooters
ever you know you ask me tomorrow I'll
say
me I'm surprised you didn't say that you
okay Game On The Line Game On The Line
Game on the line I'm coming to me man no
no about that I I think a lot of people
would agree uh let me I don't know if
you've seen Victor W bayama play in
person uh but I'm curious how Greg
papovich will use him in his rookie year
I think Greg is gonna let him do
whatever he wants to do because it I'm
not even just looking at his play his
ability to see the game and think the
game is like a 10year vet and that's
what has impressed me the most you know
his size of course he can put it on the
floor he can dunk from anywhere but his
ability to think the game and anticipate
things is on a whole another level yeah
I'm wondering he's already gone through
this with the Admiral and he went
through this with Tim Duncan and I'm
wondering if he brings him along slowly
I don't know if the Spurs are a playoff
team but you know do you just ease him
in do you have a minute restriction on
him or you just let him go full full uh
Speed Ahead I think you just throw him
in the deep end and let let what
happened happens because that's the best
way to learn you think about all the
great who played this game they started
out rookies playing almost 70 games a
season they learn by fire and I think
that's best for him I know everybody
thinks pop is the one that started this
thing of resting players but this guy is
Young I know he played a lot of minutes
overseas but hey he can play you know
make sure he tells the trainer staff and
pop how his body's feeling so he doesn't
get injured because you know as rookies
we think we can play every all 82 but
sometimes that body says no no no but
also I'm I'm watching he's going to lead
the league in Block shots he's he's no
doubt he can C he can be a rim protector
and he can also protect the three-point
line by taking one step is there what's
it like to play against somebody who's
that tall man I remember playing against
man bow and Mark Eaton those guys are
just you know tall and and and what you
have to do is just go to the other side
of the floor and hope whoever's on that
side of the floor can knock down shots
or you screen them push them under the
basket do little things to try to negate
their length and get them out of the way
because you there's one thing we always
say you can't teach size and his size is
above and beyond anybody's eyes ever
seen that's that that athletic who has
the most pressure playerwise on them
this
year I I think you know on on the low
low is yic because if you think every
year that thinks he should win the MVP
that the defending champs I think he's
going to have the most pressure but I
think out of all the players he's going
one that's going to be like I don't
really care about this pressure I'm just
going to go out and play you know I
think him in the close second is
probably Tatum because you know Boston
has been right there on the cusp but
getting to the finals and winning the
finals that I think he's going to have a
lot of pressure on him also do you think
that if Dame didn't go to Milwaukee that
Giannis would have signed that
extension no no I don't I don't think so
I I I think you know he from listening
to his conversations he wants to win and
the thing that I love most about he
doesn't care where he is he just wants
to win he's not trying to be friends
with players in any like a lot of these
guys are from playing a ball and growing
he just wants to go out and compete hard
and bring home a championship can
Lillard be a second
option I I you know what people always
say second first I don't think it's a
first or second option when it comes to
that two I think whoever's hot that
night who has the better opportunity to
score offensively because it's all about
matchups and I think with those guys who
Whoever has the better matchup would
take over that night okay but Kobe and
Shaq was was that dependent on the
matchup that they had that's a different
Beast you talking about Shaq here now
Shaq had the advantage each and every
night man there's nobody out there who
stop Shaq so I I think with that it just
Shaq had the advantage every night and
Kobe just played off him very well you
know if you watch the way Kobe played
with Shaq it was totally different when
he played with you know pal and and
those type of guys so it's I think Kobe
was so smart that he could figure it out
and adjust his game to whatever who was
on the court with him what's it like to
run into
Shaq I didn't like running into him in
practice at all you know he's such a big
guy you didn't take a charge on Shaq
ever did you no man I'm smart I got out
of the way you know you it's certain
things is know you don't you do not do
as take a charge from Shaq take a charge
from mailman it's certain guys you just
get out of the way and just say oh coach
I missed that assignment what' you think
Shaq uh had a comment about you being in
the Hall of Fame how about that uh tweet
that he sent out you know um Rudy T Shaq
Kobe all these guys have said it before
you know it for me I'm just GNA you know
sit back and let what be will be because
I'm not going to get in this debate
because you know with all these people
on Instagram Twitter whatever it may be
they want to comment and say I don't if
I don't I don't if I do I do it's up to
whoever the powers be so I'm just gonna
sit back and wait but thank you Shaq I
love you that's my brother why don't you
just take a picture of all your rings
and put it and just put it out there on
social media I've had so many people
that want me to do the picture like Bill
and Mike to do it but I just that's just
not who I am okay I'm not going to
flaunt it out there but every now and
then when someone talks trash I have it
as my screen saver when I do when I do
something like
this but if you did it and you just said
look if I don't make it to the hall of
fame I've been rewarded because I have
these and these are more important
because of all the great teams I played
on then you're not bragging you're just
letting people know hey I had an
unbelievable career and you know if I
don't make the Hall of Fame I've got
this and this is more important when I
did Special Forces they asked me that
question how do I feel about not being
in Hall of fam I said I can give you a
line like Alabama's player of the year
Alabama academic Player of the Year all
FC all defense you know if you you talk
about Hall of Fame career it's not just
what you do in the NBA it's a Basketball
Hall of Fame if it was about the NBA we
would have the NBA Hall of Fame and you
look at what I've done from the start
high school until now there's no
question I should be in it and there's a
lot of guys that should be in and I'm
not just just talking about myself
because it's the Basketball Hall of Fame
it's what you've done over your career
and I think people forget that
sometimes why don't you have the Jersey
behind you hanging on the wall I I I
haven't Gary Carter you know I love Gary
Carter I love the Mets I just haven't
had a perfect place to put it I want to
put it in my game room this is my office
yeah but the last time I talked to you
you still had it on the floor Robert I
know because it's not my game room I
hate to say this my game room I came
home one day and my wife had put all my
uh jerseys all my Championship jerseys
up so it took up to Gary Carter space I
what I had in mind to do she didn't do
she did what she wanted to do so I just
haven't taken down I want to you know I
like that you have enough jerseys that
there's no room for Gary Carter's New
Jersey that's what you take a picture of
these are my Championship jerseys we're
talking to Robert Ory the Lakers
Spectrum sports analyst and uh he joins
us on behalf of bet online what do you
want to tell us about bet online I think
bet online is the ultimate place to go
to do all your betting you know there's
so many other people out there but I
think bet online gives you the best odds
they give you good payouts and plus I've
been dealing with bet online years and
years and years so I I trust them and
you need to check them out and plus they
give you great odd you think about B
aost Celtics and the Milwaukee Bucks
they have 4 to1 odds to win the
championship but the one I like best and
I think the one everybody should bet on
is jic winning the MVP that's nine to2
and I think he's going to win the MVP
because I think you know I hate to say
this because I want my Lakers to win I
think they're the team to beat and they
have the greatest chance to win the
championship is James Harden worth
trading for if you're the Clippers I
think if I'm a GM and an owner I want to
have a meeting with James and see his
head and said listen this is we going to
try to make this your last stop we ain't
doing all this back and forth with
negotiating and we're going to have a
clause in here if you act up we get to
negate your contract or whatever it may
be and go on a different route but I
think James still has a lot left you
know you think about if you put him on a
team let's say like you know OKC you
know OKC is a young team but you got a
vet and he can really teach Shay gild
Alexander who I love to how you know to
score and be you know that guy who can
get to the free throw line get those
extra bucks from the free throw line I
think he'd be great oh sent him to New
York New yor know alongside Jaylen
Bronson there's a lot of places I think
he can fit but if I had my choice I'd
make him stay right where he is because
when you have a big like embiid and him
a dynamic guard they can do damage I
just he was great during the regular
season Robert and then all of a sudden
he he decided he wanted to be the old
James Harden if I get 21 and 11 from him
that
awesome but that's where I'd want to
stay but you know I guess he still wants
to go to the Clippers um help me
understand the Lakers Supporting Cast
and where do they where do you see them
as far as the rankings in the west there
I know a lot of let's just say this the
West is tough um but it all you know
let's be honest it depends on ad's
health and LeBron you know LeBron 21
Seasons ad has a history of problems of
getting injured but I think if you
overall you that ruy you got AR you got
so many guys and when Veno gets Health
he's that type of person that can guard
anybody like a like a JW like a Murray
he can do that kind of length on him so
I think if you look at this roster and
additions they added with Prince I think
they got pretty much the same Ross up
but tweaked a little bit better so and
plus you know the way Denver has been
talking bad about them all season and
using them as a you know a jukebox sort
of playing off them I think they have a
lot of motivation this year to go out
and try to win a chip how does Chris
Paul work out with golden state it makes
them small makes them fast and but with
Chris Paul you know he's such a great
player talented smart he knows the game
like the back of his hand he's gonna
make that team better they're gonna be
little let's let's not forget that they
gonna be little but hey Chris Paul can
give you so much you know intensity and
we always talk about Draymond Green his
nastiness that's not for forget Chris
braw brings a little nasty to the game
too and I mean that in a good way not in
a bad way in a good way who tried to
intimidate
you oh man Charles Barkley tried to
intimidate me Dennis Robin tried to
intimidate but how did they try to
intimidate you well this is one game I
remember we running down the court and
charges elbows me right in the middle of
the stomach right in front of dick pava
and I look at dick and dick just shrugs
and then I come back down and I just
like hit him in the back of his neck say
hey don't do that to me you from Auburn
too and I hate people from Auburn so you
know messed up now but yeah you know but
back in the day guys would do that they
were that that was that you know we
always talk about that welcome to the
NBA moment guys would test you to see
where your heart was see if you was
going to come out you know and step up
to the plate and and and be that guy say
okay you're going to hit me I'm going to
hit you back and we're not going to you
know go that route so you don't do that
anymore today guys are like said they're
they're more you know finesse type of
guys and say of brutes did you ever get
punched no never i' never been punched
never see I thought Rodman was just a
nuisance I did I didn't think he was
dirty I I thought he very very smart
player but he would do things like to
push you it wasn't dirty like elbow was
things to try to get you off your game
and see if you going to react because if
you boxing all of a sudden you hear you
know pushing the back or pushing the
side it irritates you so but you know
Rodman just you know he want to this is
what I want to say about Rodman people
don't understand about Rob if you go you
always talk about IQ one of the smartest
players ever to play this game you think
about it he never missed a free throw
when he needed to make one and he always
knew where the ball was going when it
was shot he can look at the trajectory
of the ball and just run to a spot and
nine times out of 10 and a fall in his
hand he was such a smart player if you
could be coached by one of your coaches
your entire career Phil Rudy
pop this is going to go on a sde I'm
going have to pick Rudy T cuz Rudy T ran
plays from me them other two never ran a
play for
me that's fair enough hey I want some
play man for me so I'm going Rudy T and
plus he's the one that say I should be
in the Hall of Fame I gotta go what's it
like to go down the floor knowing that
the play is not gonna they're they're
not calling the play for you you know
it's it's it's it's hard at times
especially when you're dealing with guys
who deserve the ball you know you think
about the people I play with Shaq Kobe
you can't say oh I should get a play
before those two guys that's not true
and then you go with Tim Manu and Tony
should you get a play before those three
no but you know every now and then when
you hot you be like yo man you better
give me the ball I'm hot but it's it's
just one of the things you love playing
the game you love the win you know you
go out and you try to win championships
and that's what we play this game for to
be winners and not go out and try to
make a lot of money like a lot of guys
like to say but I went out to try to win
games you know put myself in an elite
group or calling ourselves a champion
well you hang up the Gary Carter Jersey
the next by the next time next all you
got you going to put me on I'mma hang it
up actually I'm going hang it up in that
spot just for you so when it hangs up so
you can actually see
it good to talk to you Robert thank you
have a great season great to talk to you
too see you soon Robert Dory Lakers
Spectrum sports analyst a Jin this
courtesy of bet online updated NBA title
conference uh division Awards odds all
there always good to talk to him he's
fun